so at this stage of our point of
view, the more effectively we
explain what is happening from the point of view of
geopolitical games. Probably the sooner the
world will understand that this
needs to end and end. This is
necessary only if we
observe the cessation of attempts, not even
attempts, but such
persistent persistent  the line of the West,
led by the United States, will never end all this.
We are also preparing
some such reports on what
happened this year. What we managed to
discover. And this is not only the
military-biological programs of the
United States, from which they
are trying to disown, they are lying as always, and
this is not only direct  the participation of the United
States in the explosions of the northern streams has
now already been carried out by Mrs. Nuland, in fact, she has made a
confession. So there is a lot of things that need to be
remembered and shown. By what
methods the
United States achieves its
hegemony, we act in the same way as our
Western colleagues promised there should be
victory on the battlefield, this is their formula  it was
they who refused negotiations and forced the
Kiev regime
to leave the negotiation process, and at the
very moment when, back at the end of March,
as you know, there was an opportunity to end
this politically if now
we are striving to move the
artillery of the Ukrainian armed forces to
such a distance that will not
pose a threat to ours  territories, the more
long-range
weapons are supplied to the Kiev regime,
the further they will need to be moved away from the
territories that are part of our
country and this escalation, you are absolutely
right, this is
how the snowball began, it
all began with some kind of
paints for
Ukrainian military personnel, then
small arms appeared now  they talk
all about airplanes